dominique gonthier chez 56 ans je suis
de la majorité municipale du tampon
conseiller départemental faisant partie
de la commission des infrastructures et
grands travaux récemment
élu sur le 24e cantons représentant les
eaux de la plaine des cafres jusqu'au
d'aci mon attachement la pdk j'ai grandi
à la peine des caf originaire des hauts
je connais bien le le terrain je connais
bien les habitants des hauts et un petit
peu a besoin au quotidien
concernant les travaux qu'on aura à
faire sur la plaine des câfres sur le
canto 24 se sont continuité parce que
l'équipe municipale et les élus de cette
majorité qui était déjà aux départements
ont déjà avancé sur certains projets ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui dont les la
continuité c'est vrai qu'on va apporter
un petit peu plus
les besoins
ruraux les besoins des agriculteurs le
problème de l'eau est en train de se
régler aussi grâce au département à
l'investissement du département depuis
ses nombreuses années on est en voie
d'achèvement il nous reste quelques
retenues à faire et les voiries
agricole qui est quand même une priorité
sur ce mandat à le faire pour le
développement de l'agriculture et l'agro
tourisme aussi qui est un acteur très
important développement des os
le département a des compétences très
élargi et être conseiller départemental
c'est vraiment les mettre en application
accompagner les rionnais au quotidien de
leurs problèmes voilà ce qui nous attend
sur ce mandat voilà ce qu'on a envie de
faire pour les rionnais pour la
population tamponnais et tamponnaise
nous avons déjà commencé un bout de
chemin il nous reste encore du travail à
faire les familles en ont besoin dans
cette situation conclut catastrophiques
de cette crise sanitaire l'isolément de
ces familles ce lien qu'on a et cette
qualité qu'on a chez les familles il
faut le retrouver rapidement et nous
notre rôle c'est de faire le lien entre
cette population et le département et de
m comme il le faut ces mesures à la
disposition de ses habitants